I am Jess Holz, and I normally make artwork
with the scanning electron microscope to create
these sort of alien landscapes.
This time, I actually imaged the moon and
the sun with my dad's telescope.
I was just sort of struck by how peering down
the eyepiece of a telescope feels a lot like
peering down the eyepiece of a microscope.
Just the way you have to sort of hold your
head and eyes at a certain angle and the way
the image sort of evades you.
I also looked at the sun so this is just through
my cell phone through a filter.
This is through the telescope now, kind of
like, in the palm of your hand.
And then the next slide here is the final
image.
And you can see a little dark speck, a sunspot
on it.
And I was sort of amazed at the fact that
the sunspot could be possibly the size of
the earth.
Now in microscopy you see a lot of junk like
maybe little dark specks or a lot of debris,
but usually these things are like 100 nanometers
and, you know, very inconsequential.
But on the sun this thing is like the size
of the Earth.
That just kind of blew my mind.